relatable mainstream life
improvements
it's all about how you play the game
the game of life
are you playing it with the growth
mindset
are you playing it to learn
and adapt and
be happy and peaceful
and be in service
to life
i found that those are keys
and in a sense
when we look at how we play this game of
life
from the basics
we can in a very relatable way
improve ourselves incrementally
so let's start things off with the very
root
which is clean air water food
shelter and this is why the
sustainable development goals have such
a deep focus on this
so
if you're struggling with clean air go
where
there is clean air
and it can be difficult to do things
like leave behind the environments that
have
a contaminated water system
to look for where there is clean
available water but we must
make these transitions in order for us
to
experience the deeper essences of life
that are beyond
the fundamental root needs
and as time goes on
we will also provide more efficiently
clean water to
people around the world
food is another one if you
lack a source of food nearby
go to where there is that extra
food go to where food is more plentiful
go to where food is more healthy
because that daily source of nourishment
is what's going to enable
again all of these deeper possibilities
and essences to open up
same thing with shelter as well
to go where
shelter is as much of
a human right as possible where clean
air
water food shelter are as much
in abundance and human rights as
possible
and now i'll set this root level
foundation which will then
enable the flower to
more swiftly frictionlessly blossom
and to explore these next
possibilities
and this is also a good thing if you do
have access to clean air water food
shelter these basic needs at the root
level to do your best to also
bring other people into these
communities and environments
that don't necessarily have access to it
in their local areas
to bring them in to that abundance as
much as we can
next is
electricity computers phones
education communication
so once these root level basic needs are
met
the next thing that's so mission
critical is
do you have the technology that enables
communication and education
because the thing is especially now
in the modern day is that
your ability to learn
anything you want even
the alphabet and language
at the earliest ages all the way to
the complexities of biology
and the interior workings of a cell
are available for free on the internet
and so having electricity
and then having computers
phones for education communication
is so critical for being able to unlock
these next possibilities
you can begin asking yourself what am i
interested in beyond the fundamentals of
the alphabet and language in basic
math and basic reading and writing
and communication skills
and science and history
and spirituality that
gaining access to the computer
and internet is right there
at this root level mission critical
so one of the things that we can do to
improve the lives
of people at this level
is to help them get familiar
with computers and the internet and how
they can
leverage it for whatever they would like
to learn
and however they would like to improve
their lives
using technology it's so profound
so that's a massive component to this is
that
educational process around using
computers in the internet
and around leveraging them for
communication
so the next thing is family
and with family some of the core things
to check into are what is the size of my
family
the health of my family how close am i
in proximity to my family and what is my
general level of involvement with my
family
and so you may have both a mom and a dad
you may have some brothers and sisters
you may only be raised by one parent you
may be an only child
you may have familial conditions where
the
health of certain members is
deteriorating
where there might be a lot of anger or
a lot of frustration or a lot of anxiety
building in the relationships with
family members or it might be really
healthy
and really happy and really peaceful
and so this is where the idea of also
proximity and involvement comes into
place is that
well
at what age are you feeling
like it's appropriate for you to
potentially
leave in proximity so if you're born in
a smaller
town and you you're feeling called to
explore
new possibilities and you want to move
to a metropolis
you may be a thousand or two thousand
kilometers away from your family
and you may be much less involved with
them
and so this also creates a deep question
inside
which is well did i
come to earth
was i birthed here
for being involved deeply
with my family and
for many of us the answer to that
question is no
because we came and rebirth for specific
lessons and experiences that we
typically find
in these metros we typically find by
meeting new people
and this is typically what people call
their brothers or their sisters
is all these new people that they meet
that they feel a really strong resonance
with
and so this is really important for life
improvements
is to recognize and create a balance
with the amount of proximity and
involvement we have with our
nuclear family versus with
all of these other new friends and
people that we end up creating with
and what they can teach us and what we
can teach them
in those relationships much of the time
we find our our mentors
especially within this
category of people that are a couple
decades
older than us and we ask them these
questions
about life and they help answer these
questions in ways that
our family members are typically very
biased around
answering and so we want to expose
ourselves to
these sages that have already accrued
these decades of wisdom
and so we need to be very swift with
finding who these people are at the
youngest ages possible
and so this plays into these next couple
points
which is that to identify what your
north star what your blueprint what your
calling is
what excites you the most and this is
not just a career so this isn't just
nine to five
work but this is deeper than that this
is
internally and in your heart in your gut
in your mind what does it feel like
you're here to
do what did you come to earth to learn
how did you come to
express yourself here
and so what is that north star what are
you blueprinted for
as this divine aim that you can
organize your life around
and so that's typically around your
highest excitement and your highest
resonance and typically we don't
associate the word career
with this this is your entire purpose
your entire life orientation
so are you here
to build really good software
are you here to make really profound art
are you here to
open a local business in your community
are you here to be a really good father
or mother to some children
and so there's this wide buffet of
options
for what is this north star this
blueprint
is calling because it can be
impacting millions of people but it can
also be just impacting
a couple people in your community and
all of those
options are on the color wheel of
possibility
in this buffet of possibility and so
feeling into
what you're here to learn and experience
and express is very
very important and to align your life
around that so the life is not just
scattered but instead the life is very
aligned your life becomes very aligned
and so this is also where finding good
friends and collaborators to create with
comes in play
because as you look around for these
collaborators we mentioned
mentors as one of them earlier you'll
also find
as we said earlier brotherhood
sisterhood
these really close friends and so
what is a good mechanism to determine
what is a good friend
and so typically
you could say that they want the best
for you and you want the best for them
and that you're constantly playing with
each
other around how to help one another
execute these north stars these biggest
goals you're just checking in with each
other
about how to help one another
maybe there's something deep that you
need to process
around your around maybe
moving from your hometown to a new area
and your friend can
help you with that process so these are
what good friends
are they want the best for you you want
the best for them and you constantly
play with each other
on that whereas very static
or stagnant
friendships are ones that don't
necessarily motivate
each other too much they're very
complacent
and sometimes you can spark those
friendships
but many times they're those people are
very much blueprinted for what they're
doing
and so you can sometimes do your best to
try and be a catalyst
a spark but many times it's important to
know when to move on to new friends
to move on to new mentors to move on to
new frontiers
to move on to new collaborators to
create with
this is a great question to ask yourself
is what do you look for
in a co-founder of a project
what do you look for in people that you
build with or create with
are you looking for people that you can
trust
very intimately people that are
responsible people that are accountable
people that are well skilled
so these are good characteristics to
look for
in collaborators that you want to create
with
another mainstream life improvement
is productivity hacks
and so if you haven't already
started using software these best
technologies
i would highly recommend doing that for
example as you see here
this is evernote which is software that
i use for note taking
it's incredible software for it
and it enables me to more easily be able
to journal
and organize my ideas and execute them
and create notes for many different
topics of life
it's a big productivity hack and so is
simple things like google calendar when
you
create events
with people you say that you're gonna
call someone at two o'clock on tuesday
do you put it in your calendar do you
send them a calendar invitation
and when you organize your life this way
it makes it so that you show up more as
accountable
you show up more as responsible you show
up
more as someone that other people want
to play with that they want to create
with
that people want you to be their
co-founder
and so over time you want to
show up more and more in the world as
somebody that is responsible and
accountable
and is a good creator to collaborate
with
so use these best technologies as
productivity hacks
and figure out what those best
technologies are for you
eq means emotional quotient so
when you talk to other people do you
know how to empathize
do you know how to ask them good
questions about themselves
do you know how to genuinely lovingly
listen to them
do you know how to give nonverbal
communication
do you know how to ask good follow-up
questions
do you know how to come from a place of
service of serving them
because when you build a high amount of
emotional quotient
emotional intelligence all of your
relationships with your family your
friends your mentors
people you create with even people
online
all those relationships increase in
quality because you've learned
how to optimize the dynamic of when two
people
get into contact with each other
whereas those that are not as
emotionally intelligent or don't have as
much of an emotional quotient
will come from a place of wanting to
always extract
things when they're in a relationship
with another person
when they enter into a dynamic of
conversation with somebody
they'll be wondering what's in it for me
what can i get out of this
and so ultimately the emotional quotient
harmonizes
when you meet the right people you
equally
ask each other good questions show each
other genuine love and interest
in exploring
it's a very important productivity hack
so is 10 ideas per day
so for example if you
feel like you want to increase your
creativity
one of the best ways to do that is this
10 ideas per day
so just set a little timer for 10
minutes
and open up a note and for 10 minutes
write down 10 really good ideas
and they could be just a sentence or you
could maybe write about it for a
paragraph
but the thing is is that wherever you
look
on a daily basis to be working this
muscle of creativity
and when you do that the more and more
you practice
the more you come from a place of
desiring to
improve life for yourself and for
everyone else
and so this is a really good
productivity hack
is this 10 ideas per day it's great for
creativity
and this last one around studying using
the power law
the power law is simply put
that when you study a field like for
example biology
you can obtain eighty percent of the
most profound revelations in biology by
studying just
twenty percent of the information in
biology
so for example in biology you would want
to learn about the cell
the fundamental unit you would also want
to learn about dna
you would want to learn about proteins
and so
this is the general all of the kingdoms
of biology
and so you would want to study
the 20 of biology that's going to give
you 80 percent of the revelations
and similarly with computer science or
with spirituality
or whatever you're studying is identify
what the top 20 percent of the most
profound things you can learn
from those fields so that way you can
get
eighty percent of the profound
revelations from the shortest amount of
time
investment this is very important
another way to think about this is
parsing for signal
this is a great fast way to improve your
life in a very relatable way
is when you look at something think
about
not only how you can creatively improve
it
but also think about
when i care about studying something how
do i extract the essence
from what i care about studying
the essence how do i distill out the
most
important understandings of these fields
so perpetually check in with yourself
about that
that's a really good way to improve your
life quickly is to focus
more on the signal as much on the signal
as you can just like with the north star
the blueprint the calling
is to focus more of your time and energy
and effort
on that divine aim just like with this
field
you want to focus more of your time
energy and effort on the core
learnings from that field so those are
some productivity hacks
and then another one's exploring
romantic relationships
when we do this it's important to
come from a place of
already being whole so instead of
wanting a romantic relationship because
you feel
a void you
want a romantic relationship for an
exploration
because you feel like you can serve them
and they can serve you
really well not only sexually
but also intellectually
exploratively and this can be for a
short
short term relationship or this could be
even potentially for marriage and
children
or maybe your romantic relationships are
more around just non-sexual
play there's many different tastes
and variations that are possible
in the romantic relationships but to
improve your life from a perspective of
coming
from being whole so you approach
romantic relationships
not from a place of lack or from a place
of meeting
but rather from a place of exploration
and then the other person
will clearly see that and they will also
be more open and feel more
free to the exploring process
rather than trying to own each other
which leads to lots of frustration and
anger
and misery and that plays into
our next point
which is how to suffer less and
experience more peace and joy
and so in the most relatable
way to explain this would be
to use your breath specifically
to create more joy and peace for
yourself
because typically what happens is when
we get angry
or frustrated or anxious or depressed
if we simply break the chain of
thinking between all those thoughts
which all we have to do is just go
and remember to breathe
that can break the chain of suffering of
angry depressive thoughts
and then we just relax away those
tensions
in those depressive angry thoughts
we relax them away
and maybe we go out for a walk in the
sun we listen to the birds chirp for a
bit
maybe we read one of our favorite books
or we watch one of our favorite shows or
we pass some time with a favorite friend
but it's very important for us to become
more and more sovereign
in experiencing less suffering because
those
thought chains between angry and
depressive thoughts
if we don't become more sovereign and
use the breath as a tool
to do so to relax away the tensions
typically what happens is we end up
creating a butterfly effect of our anger
and depression
onto other people around us
and so this also plays into this next
point around how to feel
more unity and oneness and create from
there
and so when you look at the universe
itself
you think about it as universe as
one song and so when you think about it
that way
you you realize more and more that not
only the
earth is one earth with all of its
planet with all of its plants and
animals and inhabitants humans there's
one civilization here there's one
galaxy there's one universe
and when you do that process of one
planet
one galaxy one universe one creator
one infinite unity
one infinite oneness
it feels so much more relaxing you feel
so much more at home on this planet
because there's
all of these other planets and there's
all these other
galaxies there's all these other
universes
with their own explorations happening
but the one thing that you can keep
coming back to is this very
feeling from the heart space
that is this oneness that is this unity
that all the plants and animals and
humans on this planet
are one with each other you can't even
take
an inhalation without the
interdependence on phytoplankton and
trees that are oxygenating the planet
so you're so intimately related even
through your breath to this oneness and
this unity
similarly to your mother who gave birth
to you and her mother who gave birth to
her
and her mother who gave birth to her
there's such a deep interconnected
interdependent
unity and oneness among everything
and when you remember that you create
from there
so you create from a place of
stewardship or place of
shepherding a place of love
a place of unity that's where you create
from
from harmony
so rather than from a place of lack
or from a place of unworthiness or from
a place of
separation or from a place of ego
instead you come
from a place of oneness from a place of
unity from a place of love
from a place of harmony and you know it
experientially in your heart
that that's the case across all planets
across all galaxies across all universes
is an infinite oneness
and that this planet is one exploration
of that
and so we share our being we share our
existence
and that's so important to feel because
it decreases suffering it decreases
anxiety decreases depression and it
increases peace it increases joy it
increases planetary prosperity
very very important life improvement
and then just the incrementalness
of opening new possibilities so if for
example
you were wondering okay if i'm going
between this
chain of thinking just to be able to
catch yourself
one time with breath
and to relax away the tension of that
thought that was causing suffering
to relax it away
one incremental improvement like that
opens
so much possibility and be proud of
yourself
one little improvement like that is big
time
for example if you didn't necessarily
know what your north star
or your what you were blueprinted for
what felt like you're calling
just even opening up a note and writing
down
five or ten possibilities of what you
feel like your north star is
is a huge improvement this is one
incremental improvement
that opens up so much possibility
because guess what the next day
when you open up that note with the five
or ten ideas of what your north star
might be
you'll feel maybe a little bit more
interest in one or two of them and
you'll start researching
on what those one or two options are
and so you see how daily incrementally
you open up new possibilities
but it requires this process of
unfreezing
what is your will unfreezing
what has been this stagnant or the
static perpetuation
of what has been running for a while as
your scripts
and so to unfreeze your will to these
new possibilities through
simple daily incremental
improvements is so important
and i love you so much you're already
whole
you're already perfect you're already
divine
as you are and so tune in
what might be these ways that i would
improve my life
white might be these softwares that i
might begin using
that might make my use of technology
more impactful and more frictionless
what might be a good way for me to
surround myself with people that have
more of a growth mindset
what might be a good way for me to go to
a local meetup
in one of the fields that i'm interested
in
and you see how these things compound on
each other
and so more and more possibilities
end up opening up over time
so it's very very important
to have a more clear
understanding of knowing yourself
how are you playing the game of life
and how can you improve the way that you
play the game of life
this has been some simple relatable
mainstream life improvements
productivity hacks ways of seeing
things and just incrementally
improve yourself daily
and you'll see possibilities open up of
more
peace of more joy of more actualization
of more unity of more oneness
and you'll feel so much better
and will all prosper more harmoniously
i love you so much let me know how this
resonated
in the comments below and how i can
serve you how i can help you
like the video it helps the algorithm
we'll get it out to more people
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet share the video with other people
that you feel like this
list and exploration would help with
that's all i love you thank you
and i hope this serves you so well
go get it
much love